Hi, Lily. Don't kill me, please.
Among us is a video game that has taken the world by storm.
It's one of the most watched games on Twitch and YouTube,
even politicians are playing it,
sorry,
but what if instead of this game happening on our computer
screens, it happened in real life,
which crewmates would be sus,
what sort of tasks do you need to do?
And could you survive until the end?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if among us happened in real life
for the uninitiated. Here's how among us works.
The game can have up to 10 players. The majority of them are known as crewmates.
They spend their time trying to fix their failing spaceship.
The rest are imposters or aliens.
Their goal is to stop the crew mates from repairing the ship by any means
necessary. That includes deception murder,
or just being really annoying.
The trick here is that the majority of the game is played without being able
to communicate with the other players.
The only time you're able to talk is when a meeting is called
there,
you can discuss who you think the imposter might be and shove them out of the
airlock.
If the imposter is a really good liar, you're going to have a tough time.
But if the crew mates managed to eject the imposters before it's too
late, then they win the game
and don't forget anyone who's killed can always come back as a ghost.
Now that we know more about how among us works,
what would happen if it took place in real life?
Well, for this scenario, naturally,
we're going to have it take place on a space ship and what better space ship
than the international space station.
You and nine other crew mates are on board.
You have to complete tasks on the ship or everything goes wrong.
The only problem here is that three of your other crewmates are
frequently aliens.
They are going to do everything they can to prevent you from getting your job
done. Issues on the ISS are pretty common.
And crew members often have to work together to repair them.
On September 28th, 2023.
ISS members were woken by mission control. After it was reported,
there was a leak on the ship.
The three crew members all had to work together to identify the leak and then
repair it. This was an ongoing problem.
First discovered more than a year earlier,
the crew had spent several weeks figuring out where the leak was coming from.
So unlike among us your tasks here,
wouldn't be simple mini games where you're connecting wires or destroying
asteroids.
This would require teamwork and some intricate mechanical engineering.
And just like the game,
let's assume you're wearing a space suit and you're unable to communicate with
your crew. Now you're performing an incredibly complicated task.
One that requires multiple people, and you're unable to talk to anyone.
What could possibly go wrong? Well,
now that your crew is distracted by all these complex tasks,
this would be the perfect opportunity for the imposters to cause some trouble
that you wouldn't know exactly what they're doing, but that
a dead body has been reported.
And of course it was in electrical. It's always electrical.
Now you can take off your space suit and talk to your crew,
who is the imposter?
You saw that one guy who went toward electrical,
but then you could have sworn he was helping you with the task.
You were near the one dressed in blue for a bit,
but he didn't seem to do anything strange.
Could it be? But wait, as you've been thinking during this time,
the entire crew has decided that you must be the impostor.
I guess that's what you get for being so quiet.
They've all cast their votes. And now you've been objected into space
instead of getting a harmless game overseen,
this would mean imminent death for you.
As soon as you're kicked out of the ship,
your lungs would expand and burst due to the loss of external pressure.
Your skin would balloon up from the water in your body.
You'd also get a nasty sunburn from the radiation and then suffocate to death.
If you had just told the cremates what you were doing,
you would have had a better chance. Well,
now that you're a ghost and can get a better sense of what's going on.
You see that you were right. It was the blue guy,
and now he's wiping out the West of your crew. Oh no.
And after all of your crew is gone,
the ISS would then be completely destroyed.
Let's hope that if aliens are among us,
that they're pretty obvious and we don't have to worry about anyone being sus or
not to learn more about among us, check out this week's.
What if discussed podcast? We learn the ins and outs of the game,
tips and tricks with Leanna Rupert of game informer. Check it out.